a lot of people have asked me did you
see the light at the end of the tunnel I
thought no I didn't I did there was no
tunnel and people say oh did you see any
loved ones and I was like No just Snoop
Dogg really and I thought immediately
Christ this is no drill this is for real
this is an emergency and I've got to get
this aircraft down and then I felt this
massive blow to the top of my head and I
just saw
I just saw the ground coming up towards
me cold red cold red cold red multiple
stab wounds
it was one of those Bluebird days you
know the sun was was shining down on me
you know birds in the trees kind of
twittering and I was just thinking about
what was what was coming ahead as far as
I was concerned it was just another day
solo and I was kind of our building
building up my experience and then I
would have been coming back to the UK
sort of Job Done sort of tick in the box
and that ambition complete as it were
nice and calm nice and gentle hand on
the stick and I go full throttle and I'm
starting to take off and I'm starting to
head
um higher and then once I get to a
thousand feet I can pull back gently on
the throttle and sort of level off so
the aircraft sort of goes from climbing
to sort of leveling off a thousand feet
and then I can kind of gently kind of
cruise around in the pattern and do and
do what I need to do I then did a a look
and I did a look again because I
couldn't quite believe what I saw I was
struck by an immediate
um Vision if you will of a thin streak
of visible yellow orange flame and I had
to look again because it was a it was a
shock initially and um and I realized
that it was fire and it was a thin
streak and it was emanating from the
front portion of the fuselage
and I looked down at my feet on the
rudder pedals
um I could see flame starting to lap and
around the feet and the ankles inside
the uh the Chamber of the small
two-seater cockpit that I'm sat in and I
thought immediately Christ this is no
drill this is for real this is an
emergency and I've got to get this
aircraft down
I immediately felt the heart sort of
boom boom boom within my chest you know
there I was at a thousand feet but
nowhere to go where am I going to go you
can't jump from that height people have
asked me you know did you not have a
parachute well you don't wear a
parachute in a light aircraft the only
option I foresaw was indeed to to
to try to to get out of that cockpit
early but I needed to get her the
aircraft that was to a safe level in
order to to have any you know chance of
of pulling that off cleanly and and make
it happen
my mind then flicked back to one of the
US instructors and I can distinctly
remember it and he said and I quote
above all if there is an emergency and
you've got a problem
fly the dam aircraft and these words
kind of echoed and reverberated in in my
in my memory and I and I thought I've
gotta I've gotta hold on I've got to get
a grip here and I've got to do exactly
that so I kept my left hand on the uh
the flight control stick and my right
hand on the throttle and I carefully
just knocked off that power on the
throttle to try to reduce air speed and
I needed to reduce that significantly in
order to get myself to a relatively safe
speed approaching the active Runway all
the time I'm watching the altimeter spin
down so through
903 800 feet 700 feet 600 feet and I've
got that left hand under control right
hand on the throttle
when I'm trying to breathe and I'm
trying to think through it and I'm just
trying to really calm it all down as
much as possible when I flew over the
top of the active Runway I was literally
100 feet 50 feet by the time I'd cleared
it
I turn off the key Magneto's alpha bravo
the red switch is off in the center
column fuel pump off rotate fuel
selector valve through 90 degrees off
everything off off in sequence at the
lower at the lower reaches from 50 feet
and and below the fire was literally
laughing my face I then
opened my left hand canopy door I can
remember Reaching Across fiddling with
the um
the handle I then had to Elbow it with
my left elbow and punch it and strike it
with the heel of my hand
and I'm now 50 feet 40 feet 30 feet 20
feet all the time looking checking
looking
and at 20 feet I got onto the left hand
wing
clambering over that door lip and then I
stood onto the wing and so I jumped
I would estimate at a height of about 15
one five feet in reality I was probably
traversing at about perhaps 30 knots
through the airspace and that height 15
feet so it was a it was a tremendously
hard impact even though I landed feet
first I then thrust forward I smashed my
face
on the uh on the sharp Florida razor
grass below and I remember my right
shoulder was still on fire so I
aggressively had to Pat it out and my
right scalp I could sense it was still
on fire so I patted it out the aircraft
carried on on a very low and shallow
trajectory without me and I watched her
crash land there was this ugly crumpling
crashing noise
and Extremely Loud and and very scary
and all of a sudden boom An Almighty
explosion I felt the shock of the
explosion the energy come through me and
back again and that sucked out to
all of the air that I had within the
lung
and um I held on and I don't know how I
did it
um all I can suggest is that I was a
young man at the time you know I was
just turned 32 years of age and I was as
fit as a butcher's dog by virtue of what
I did for a living uh you know with the
forces and I kept myself in in great
shape
and so I I guess I had that fighting
Edge but I still didn't have long and I
waited and and then I heard the sirens
and then the truth is um
I don't remember anything for for
realistically the next six months of my
life
I got a phone call from my girlfriend
and she's like
I could just hear a lot of commotion in
the background she basically said she's
going to All Occasion and
a guy here so
I went back to the to find my girlfriend
so
I've got back there
and the person I hit her was just
standing there like he done nothing
wrong so I've confronted him and I said
brother like why you hitting my
girlfriend for
and then basically um me and him going
to our occasion where the fight just a
physical fight it happened in a shop and
then um
I remember coming at the shop I went to
the car to get back into the car
and something just said look behind you
I looked behind me and I just saw this
guy without the longest kitchen knife I
just remember it like a big silver
kitchen there I remember him chasing me
so I started to run around the car run
around the car trying to get away from
him so every time I got to one side of
the car he was kind of like on the next
side of the car with the knife
and I was like damn and then he opened
the car door and at that time he opened
a car door
to where my missus was saying so I'm
like damn like now he's
going towards herb enough
at that time so I've jumped back over
towards the car to start fighting him
again to defend there and I remember he
had a knife in his right hand so I said
to myself
when I turn around I'm gonna try to
deflect the knife
by doing that
as I've done that
he took a step back I just went bang in
my neck
it felt like a circuit broke I had a big
flash of wire I went Bing I just heard
my age ring
I think I was going on
and after that
as soon as you've done that my arm just
dropped to the side boom
and then he'd come at me and he started
stabbing me again
and then he stabbed me and he stabbed me
I fell on the floor this is when he
stabbed me across my chest here after me
twice so the first time I goes in my
neck then the second stabbing my neck
and then I got
um stabbed in my I got a big scar across
here stab me there I believe because I
got stabbed the first time and I had
something to kind of compare it against
I knew that I was already in much more
trouble than the first time if you know
what I mean um
the blood the pain
um not bad to move my arm and after that
I went straight from thinking I've been
defeated to
I can hear police sirens
yeah so the police woman starts when
she's like what's going on we heard
there's a fight I was like no no I don't
know I'm cool she's like no listen we
heard there's a fight here you're
involved cream jacket and after she's
like she looked at me she went
cold red cold red cold red multiple stab
wounds no like my top was just turning
red by the second but I got a cream
finger now I remember my next car my
Betty's car I'm like everywhere is the
blood's just coming through me now she's
like cold red cold red cold red you put
me on the floor
it's like get ambulance and that's when
I remember where they put me in an
ambulance the first thing I kept saying
to the doctor I can't move my arm I
can't move my arm well I can't be my arm
they didn't care about that because at
that time I already lost 40 of my blood
so it is so they were just trying to
stop me from losing blood now
I I last night I remember hearing it was
my mom scream my mom screamed
and I remember like
trying to like put my put myself to have
a strong face like there's nothing wrong
with me you know I mean my mom in it
and then after that I just remember
waking up two days later in the hospital
myself and my sister was attending
friends wedding
um in the evening driving back
um I was a passenger in the car and we
had a car accident obviously I don't
remember anything about the accident but
initially after the accident
um I was fighting for my life my heart
had stopped on a couple of occasions and
I was put into an induced coma
um my body was fighting with a severity
of injuries as well as a spinal cord
injury and I was touching over quite
some time
I know at the scene of the accident I
had to be resuscitated by the Emergency
Services
and also when I got to a e I had to be
resuscitated again
do you remember being rushed to a e in
the ambulance no what it's so bizarre
though because what I do remember is
like I'm not sure whether it's
me being
conscious unconscious or
where my mind is
I don't know it's where my heart stopped
my brain has gone off in a different way
because what I remember is not actually
what happened
so at that point
um
I thought after the accident we drove
home and went back to my parents house
and my mum and dad was there but
obviously this didn't happen so that was
in my mind
um and then it
flashed to a different part where I was
at an airplane and I was being put into
the cargo with the luggage
and
I just remember it being so bright and
really really cold
um
and then my brother and my fiance Andy
was on the plane and we was all going
back to Australia and everyone was
really happy
but then it changed and
I was then in this
complete darkness in this huge open
space
and I was sitting on a chair
like stuck but stuck to a wall
and it was just empty and silent
and then I hear the door go behind me
and it was my brother and Andy
and they're so angry and I can hear them
talking and they're saying
I can't believe she didn't come through
that's it we're done we wipe our hands
with her you know my brother said to
Andy you need to forget about her now
you need to wipe your hands that's it
we're done with her we're just gonna
leave her just leave her
but I remember just sitting in the chair
and then I heard these voices
and I looked down
and I could see
I could see a light from a door like a
back entrance to a club
and I have no idea why
this person was there I I just can't
work it out but uh it was Snoop Dogg and
he had his Entourage of people with him
and they was looking to kill me but I
remember the fear and I was so scared
I tried not to make a sound I didn't
want to breathe and I was thinking oh
please don't look up please don't look
up and then my chair slowly started
peeling away from the wall like it was
stuck with velcro
and it was peeling more and more and I
was thinking oh my God please move I
don't want them to I don't want my chair
to fall and then be there and find me
as it came away from the wall then I
woke up
because a lot of a lot of people have
asked me did you see the light at the
end of the tunnel I was like no I didn't
I did there was no tunnel and people say
oh did you see any loved ones and I
thought no just Snoop Dogg really
um I don't know how long after the
dreams or however I would explain it but
when I actually woke up
I was
distraught because I thought that my
family and Andy had left me
it was so weird and bizarre I thought
that I was in a psychiatric ward
obviously I was still on traction so I
was lying flat in my back and I could
see even open my eyes I could see the
tubes coming from my throat and I wasn't
quite sure what was going on
and I was I was feeling really sad and
just low at that point because I've
thought that my family and Andy had left
me and I was on my own and I didn't
quite understand what was going on and
then my mum and dad walked around the
corner
oh and I can't tell you
how happy
and the relief I felt when I saw them
because honestly I thought that they'd
left me
and when my mum came walking up to the
bed I just burst out crying
Leeds was a really vibrant town
full of music venues Arty people and
went to meet my friends to plan my 21st
birthday party which was up and coming
in a few days time there was an
atmosphere in Leeds at the time whereby
you didn't want to stay out late and
women were encouraged not to go out
alone well I wasn't having any of that
as a 20 year old I just thought that was
ridiculous and I felt very safe and
Street wise so my friends decided that
we should leave the pub early we'd ran
out of money to be fair don't had enough
money for a few beers and then I
separated from them to walk into the
Town Center to catch my bus home
so I went on my own through the Leeds
University campus
there was a few people about it wasn't
particularly busy I think people had
already gotten home
and then I thought if I don't hurry I'm
gonna miss my bus
so I took a shortcut which was only a
side street it wasn't an alley or
anywhere dark and then I heard this
voice behind me just here
it was a really friendly friendly voice
and he said hi Hi how are you doing I
thought I'm bound to know this person
they're probably on Route into town like
me or they're you know fellow student so
I turned around and went and walked
towards him and as I got closer I didn't
recognize him at all
I noticed that he was holding himself
really oddly
as though he was
he had an arm around his side and he was
leaning a little bit but he really
wanted to engage in conversation that
much I do remember
and I I started to feel a little bit
uncomfortable
and so I said no I'm sorry yeah bye I've
got to catch a bus and I I turned round
and started to walk very quickly
their nice sense real danger because I
heard his footsteps following me and I
was heading for the end of the road
and as I walked faster I could hear his
footsteps getting faster and faster and
then sheer Panic took over
and I started to run towards the end of
the road and as I ran I could feel his
his steps getting nearer and nearer and
nearer so close behind me I had the
hairs on the back of my neck standing up
and my knees went to jelly and then I
felt this massive blow to the top of my
head and I just saw
I just saw the ground coming up towards
me and I was made completely unconscious
I'm sorry no it's fine it's got to be
sad
apparently unbeknownst to me as I don't
remember anything apart from the blow to
my head and falling to the ground I let
out a scream fortunately there was a
young couple walking at the end of the
road
right where I needed to get to and then
they saw me on the floor with this man
kneeling over me wielding something and
trying to hit me repeatedly and they ran
towards him and at that point he saw
them
and ran away and if it wasn't for them
he would have had his final blow and I
wouldn't I wouldn't be sat here today
for sure
the doctors in Orlando gave me about a
five percent probability of survival
which is extremely slim odds even though
they placed me in drug-induced coma I
was in the fight of my life I mean this
was Jamie Hull
you know
World War III I had 62 operations under
general anesthetic with a multitude of
different surgeons
for all kinds of different
reconstructive work following the burns
and to get me back on track to get me
back to a semblance of health and
normality
and indeed I had many years of work both
physically and mentally in order to
accept and in order to rehabilitate
myself and it was very important for me
to get back in the air somehow and to
fulfill that ambition
all over again and to uh to keep going I
did
fortunately uh
win a scholarship to learn to fly a hot
air balloon and I did my training in
Italy it gave me that real some that
sense of Freedom admittedly you know
what I do with the balloon from time to
time is a lot more sedate but then I
guess the new version of Jamie Hull is a
lot more sedate you know I'm not that
high speed guy that I once was and so
it's probably quite fitting really
is so
it's so loud
like a small thing
to others is a huge thing to me
I just don't want to settle I just want
to keep pushing myself I want to keep
bettering myself I want to keep making
smaller gains but it's the little things
in the meantime you know I'm just going
to keep on working harder and and just
making progress so now I I can manage to
sit in a chair like this and not only
that I can Propel myself I can push
myself around I can
feed myself I can brush my teeth I can
do my own makeup
there's so many so much stuff that I
have done now because of Physiotherapy
and because of rehab and I just want I
want to give the opportunity to others I
want other people to benefit from it as
well and I know they can it put the best
part of five to ten years
um you know let's go about a millimeter
a day and
you gotta assist that with diet good
diet and sleep and physical therapy and
good will you know I mean it's not easy
a young impulsive naive child who's
driven by social media and materialistic
stuff gets a knife in his hand
he ain't gonna know that the severity of
stabbing someone until he's sitting in
jail knowing that he's gonna have a 10
years to do or he's urinating
through some sort of medical device
or
is that if you carry a knife and you're
not going to tell it in just make sure
you're within to go Joe or you want to
die
there's no more to it live by the knife
die by the knife it's that simple I
think the most important thing that it
did give me that attack that five
minutes in the wrong place gave me the
uh
the power to just go wow I I was I could
I nearly died I nearly died I was so
close to death and a horrific death it
would have been as well mutilated I just
that's it gave me power actually it
didn't it's it doesn't Define me because
I am other things than a victim of a
crazy serial killer you know I'm a
professional I'm a practicing artist I'm
a published author Sutcliffe couldn't
take that away from me he might have
broken my bones and tried to kill me and
did change me because it gave me a Lust
For Life it gave me
are like wow I survived that almost a
responsibility to carry on you know
harder uh
and Loud shout louder to make big art to
do things and I I just wonder how I
would applauded on
if if I hadn't been attacked harness
your anger harness you you
your fear and and turn it around if you
can and use it as fuel to get you where
you want to be in your life it's really
vital that you you don't let it subsume
you and drown you and Define you
foreign
[Music]